it is April 14 2023 and you're watching
the code report we're living through a
development tooling Space Race right now
and GitHub co-pilot is just the tip of
the rocket there's a long shaft of other
tools competing in the space that's
growing girthier every day all of which
are seated by Massive foundational
models yesterday Amazon web services
released a new code generation tool
called code Whisperer and unlike its
biggest competitor co-pilot which is
powered by Microsoft and openai it's 100
free for everybody that's a huge deal
last week I made a big mistake by poking
the AWS bear with this video but this
week it comes back and totally redeems
itself it has some very cool unique
features and today we'll compare it head
to head with copilot but that's not
everything AWS just announced they also
just launched web service number
69421 called Bedrock it allows
developers to access large foundational
models on AWS infrastructure making it
possible for the average dude who
doesn't own a pile of gpus to build
highly customized AI applications it has
image models like stability AI stable
diffusion and llms like AI 21 Labs
Jurassic models in addition AWS also
announced two of its own foundational
models for both text and image
processing called Titan what's crazy for
image models is that all you need to do
to build something custom is upload some
labeled images to S3 like say you want
to make fashion models obsolete Jesse we
need to produce more Valencia
you might be able to get the job done
with as few as 20 images and if that
weren't crazy enough AWS also made its
new ml training ec2 instances generally
available which are based on inferentia
chips these are custom-built chips that
can train machine learning models at
about 50 of the normal cost on ec2 and
that means you could train your own llm
from scratch for only 5 million dollars
instead of 10 million dollars platforms
like cohere and hugging face are already
using this behind the scenes but let's
get back to code whisper which you can
use for free right now first install the
vs code or jetbrains extension then
enable it by registering open up a code
file then hit option C to generate some
code you can also open the extension
options here and enable auto suggestions
which will generate code as you go I'm
currently running it in a nexjs project
and it seems to do a pretty good job of
understanding the context of the project
like here it exported a default function
component which is exactly what I was
hoping for and as you can see here it
generated perfect use effect code for me
also you can hit the arrow keys to get
additional suggestions as needed
compared to copilot I found that it
usually doesn't suggest as much code
like typically it just goes is line by
line whereas in copilot it might suggest
50 lines of code at one time this is
both a good and a bad thing because
sometimes copilot just recommends a
bunch of annoying nonsense but it can
also be very useful when you have a lot
of boilerplate like an HTML form but
most importantly I want to make sure
this thing can write regular Expressions
it works great for simple patterns like
phone numbers but becomes harder to
prompt as the pattern gets more complex
still extremely useful though I also
want to see if this thing could write
unit tests so I created a testing file
and no joke it wrote an angular
component for some reason I think it's
trying to tell me something it kind of
failed there but it also does some
really cool things that GitHub co-pilot
doesn't like for one it will give you a
reference to the code in the training
data when producing its own code it's
awesome to have that transparency and
also makes it less likely that you
accidentally steal some code and then
use it in ways you're not allowed to the
legal picture Behind these tools is
still very murky there's a class action
lawsuit against GitHub co-pilot right
now for being trained on billions of
lines of public code without providing
Credit in addition stock image supplier
Getty Images is suing stability API for
its art generation tools it's only a
matter of time before the lawyers ruin
AI for everybody so enjoy it while it
lasts another cool feature of code
Whisperer though is security scans you
get 50 of these per month and they can
check web applications for o wasp issues
like if your site's vulnerable to
cross-site scripting or if you're
building your own coin they can
also analyze smart contracts and of
course they can point out how you're not
using AWS properly the bottom line here
is that code Whisperer might not be a
game changer but it's pretty close to
being on par with copilot and most
importantly it's free but this is only
the beginning if you were born before
2021 you might remember the days when AI
couldn't even write code you had to use
these primitive tools like Google and
stack Overflow this AI rocket is moving
fast but it hasn't climaxed yet maybe
it'll go limp and disappoint us or maybe
it's about to plant the seed for the
next generation of artificial general
programmers only time will tell this has
been the code report thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one